but as far as what's being done for the
Middle East right now it seems like such
a stalemate it seems like there are two
steps for you step two steps back for
every step forward and right now I don't
feel a lot of optimism that there's
going to be progress certainly not
through the conventional route as to say
through the political pathways that have
been entrenched in the negative approach
or so long but I do think at a
grassroots level there's a better
understanding of the need to resolve
this is that there is greatest ability
right and I do believe that resolving
especially the israeli-palestinian
situation will make a big difference to
a lot of other areas around the world
the whole Islamophobia and the
negativity that comes out of that and
the sort of the radicalization of many
Muslims comes founded on the fact that
there seems to be an imbalance or an
unfair approach to ISO meetings really
fast and in saturation so I think there
is hope at a grassroots level of moving
forward as far as the politicians I
think we have a long way to go